voilà donc chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs nous poursuivons nos travaux
sectoriels consacrés au secteur
d'activités les plus féminisées au sein
desquels les risques professionnels sont
souvent sous-estimées et les politiques
de prévention dédiées aux femmes
insuffisamment développées je rappelle
que 4 rapporteurs ont été dixièmesnés
par notre délégation pour étudier cette
thématique de la santé des femmes au
travail il s'agit de Laurence Cohen
Annick Jacquemet Marie-Pierre Richer
Laurence Rossignol et donc vous avez
face à vous trois des rapporteurs qui
sont présents ce matin notre table ronde
de ce matin la deuxième porte sur les
métiers du mannequinat et de l'accueil
métier où les femmes sont sur
représentées ou l'importance de
l'apparence et la pression de l'image
sont particulièrement prégnantes et
peuvent même être violentes au sein de
ces professions une importance
particulière est accordée au physique et
à l'âge des femmes considérées comme des
portes étendard de la féminité
outre la pression qu'elle subisse
concernant leur poids leur apparence
physique et leur âge elles sont
également parfois exposées à des
violences sexistes et sexuelles au sein
de leur environnement professionnel
s'agissant du mannequinat une loi de
janvier 2016 a prévu des dispositions
pour lutter contre la maigreur excessive
des mannequins d'une part en imposant la
mention photographique retouchée pour
les photos commerciales qui affinent ou
qui épaississent la silhouette des
mannequins d'autre part
je sais pas si ça va plus dans un sens
ou dans l'autre c'était
d'autre part en rendant j'ai senti qu'il
y avait quelques réactions parmi les
sénateurs et sénatrices présentes
d'autre part en nous ne retouchons pas
nos photos nous laisser natrices et
sénateurs
d'autre part en rendant obligatoire un
certain un certificat médical pour
l'exercice de l'activité de mannequin
délivrée par un centre médical et de
prévention qui assure le suivi exclusif
de la santé de toutes ses
professionnelles en France
Thalie santé se centre d'ailleurs décidé
de mener une enquête ciblée sur le
métier de mannequin et les maltraitances
et violences subis par les femmes qu'il
exerce cette enquête est donc en cours
je pense les hôtesses d'accueil
subissent le même genre de pression que
les mannequins s'agissant de leur
apparence physique leur poids leur âge
elles sont également fréquemment
victimes de violences sexistes et
sexuelles verbale ou physique en juillet
2019 la dénonciation de la tradition
sexiste des hôtesses sur le podium du
Tour de France suivi du hashtag viral
pas tapotiches hashtag pâte à potiche
avait permis de mettre en lumière les
conditions de travail précaires des
hôtesses d'accueil la pression des
critères physiques
creuser pour exercer cette profession
ainsi que les agressions sexuelles et
sexistes subies dans le cadre de Lara
activité donc ce matin pour cette table
ronde et pour approfondir ces cette
thématique avec ces secteur spécifique
nous avons écarterina aux iganova
mannequin fondatrice de modèles low
association française de défense et de
protection des droits des mannequins
Thierry boulanger médecin du travail
Yann Hillaire responsable des projets de
prévention et Christine Joly directrice
du développement et en charge de la
coordination de la commission mannequin
chez talisant
sociologue du travail auteur d'un
ouvrage intitulé jeune jolie et
sous-traitée les hôtesses d'accueil et
bien écoutez je vais je vous souhaite
évidemment la bienvenue ce matin au céda
je vous remercie pour votre présence et
je vais vous laisser d'abord
la parole à vous madame alors si je le
dis deuxième fois là j'ai réussi à bien
dire votre nom sans l'écorcher une seule
fois donc on va céder la parole à Madame
Ekaterina hoziganova et donc c'est à
vous madame de vous exprimer
alors vous branchez le micro et vous
l'approchez à droite à gauche voilà et
vous l'approchez bien de vous
que à la fois le compte-rendu vous
entende et que les sénatrice et
sénateurs
vous entendent bien également ça veut
pas dire que nous avons des problèmes
d'audition non pas besoin de faire
retoucher nos photos mais pas de
problème d'audition forcément non plus
merci madame la Présidente pour ce
propos introductif donc comme vous
l'avez mentionné je suis moi-même
mannequin depuis 2014 traductrice de
formation fondatrice de modelo étudiante
en droit à Paris Panthéon Assas je suis
ravie d'être présente à ces tables
rondes consacrer au sujet qui me tient
personnellement à coeur hacker et qui
fait partie intégrante de l'ADN de notre
association modelo modelo est la
première association française de
défense des droits de mannequin nous
existons depuis l'hiver 2017 et nous
avons pour objet de réunir de soutenir
de défendre les mannequins qui exercent
leur activité en France ainsi que de
promouvoir un comportement professionnel
éthique dans le milieu de la mode nos
principales actions s'articulent autour
de travail de terrain avec des
mannequins des professionnels du luxe et
des institutions soutient juridique
apporter d'une part par des avocats
exercés en barreau de Paris d'autre part
par un pôle juridique d'aide gratuite
créée un partenariat avec la clinique
juridique de l'école de formation des
barreaux de Paris la mission éducative
et le travail de recherche et d'analyse
aux côtés de l'anthropologue du
lamensityri puisque le surjet à l'ordre
du jour est la santé mentale et physique
des mannequins j'aimerais structuré mes
propos autour de trois points tout
d'abord un diagnostic les problèmes de
santé physique comme mental sont une
part quasi inévitable de la carrière de
mannequin des solutions existent
qu'elles viennent du législateur ou des
acteurs du secteur privé mais ils sont à
notre sens inadapté et c'est pourquoi
modelo souhaiterait encourager le
législateur et les acteurs du secteur à
développer certaines mesures afin de
dresser la liste des préoccupations
principales nous nous sommes servis de
nos propres sondages menés auprès des
mannequins français et internationaux à
différents moments entre 2018 et
aujourd'hui nous ne sont également basés
sur les quelques études qui existent en
la matière plutôt un régime ainsi j'en
citerai que deux aujourd'hui
la première étude dont j'aimerais vous
parler et celle de Nicolette Bogart
c'est une ancienne mannequin
internationale d'origine hongroise et la
poursuivi sa carrière dans le domaine
médical doctorante aujourd'hui et la
publie en 2019 en livre tiré de sa
recherche et de combat personnel avec
les troubles alimentaires qui
s'appellent je fais la traduction un peu
personnelle l'industrie de la mode et
les troubles alimentaires les dangers du
podium coécris avec Docteur
ferensoury professeur des sciences
comportementales au sein de l'université
de semel Vares comme je l'ai précisé
plus haut les données sur la fréquence
de troubles alimentaires chez les
mannequins sont très rares et les
échantillons sont souvent de petites
tailles si plusieurs études ont prouvé
les effets négatifs de l'idéal de beauté
du fusée par les médias sur la
population générale les effets de
citadelle sur l'industrie de la mode et
ses propres employés n'ont pas encore
été étudiés à en profondeur la recherche
de Madame Bogarde 2019 a permis de
confirmer plusieurs observations de
terrain que nous avons pu faire à
travers nos activités et notamment du
fait que les mannequins subissent dans
leur quotidien une forte pression pour
maintenir un corps mince et atteindre
certaines mensurations la taille 0 le
tour de hanche ne devant surtout pas
dépasser les 90 cm ce qui augmente
nécessairement le risque de
développement des symptômes de troubles
alimentaires dans une étude la plus
récente publiée par Madame Bogart en
2022 il était question de déterminer si
les mannequins sont plus susceptibles
que les autres personnes de développer
des troubles alimentaires les chantilly
de cette étude a été significativement
supérieur en taille à celui des études
similaires l'étude se concentre sur les
mannequins de taille dit standard donc
sans prendre en compte les modèles plus
size cette étude confirme que l'indice
de masse corporelle ou l'IMC moyen de
mannequin professionnel et largement
inférieur à la limite inférieure de 18,5
pour 18,5 et bien qu'il soit important
de garder à l'esprit que les mannequins
peuvent être génétiquement plus fines et
plus grandes que la moyenne est donc
l'échantillon moyen de personnes qui ne
font pas ce métier à l'étude conclut à
ce que approximativement 44% des
mannequins participants ont un IMC
compris entre 18,5 et 17 et 21% ont
déclaré à l'IMC
[Musique]
un outre a été mis en lumière
l'insuffisance des protections qui sont
en place en ce que les mannequins
avouent subir généralement la pression
relative à leur apparence physique de la
part des agents de mannequins ou des
créateurs de mode c'est ce qui ressort
également de notredage lancé il y a
quelques jours ou parmi les 40
répondants 90 % en confirmé le fait de
ressentir cette pression de façon
systématique ou occasionnelle et 80% on
établit un lien direct ou en direct
entre leurs problèmes de santé mentale
et leur travail de mannequin en 2017 une
autre étude a démontré que 62% des
mannequins participants se sont vu
conseillés par des professionnels du
secteur de perdre du poids ou de
modifier leur proportion corporelle se
tonifier en quelque sorte si vous voulez
avoir plus du succès dans leur carrière
cette pression extérieure a conduit
selon les auteurs à des comportements
malsains de contrôle du poids tels que
le des régimes le sport à outrance
l'utilisation de laxatif les
vomissements auto enduits etc
à défaut de ce de se mettre en
conformité avec les attentes du secteur
les mannequins deviennent souvent
victimes de ce qu'on appelle le body
shaming la honte du corps ce qui peut
s'analyser comme une forme de
harcèlement moral au travail cela me
permet de faire un lien avec un autre
étude que je me réciter aujourd'hui
c'est le fruit du travail aussi d'une
ancienne mannequin international
d'origine polonaise cette fois-ci elle
s'appelle magdalenachosvska elle est
diplômée dans master scientifique en
santé mentale et les co-fondatrices de
groupes de soutien pour les mannequins
qui est basé à Londres qui s'appelle moi
dans un powerworld cette étude a été
publiée en 2022 en collaboration avec
plusieurs chercheurs et étant à
démontrer que les agences adoptent un
comportement irresponsable inversé
jeunes travailleurs en les mettant
systématiquement en danger un effet les
agences plutôt soucieuses de faire du
profit nos questions ne jamais vraiment
les stéréotypes qui sont véhiculées par
la société dans son ensemble mais aussi
par l'industriel même elle minimise
ainsi l'impact des dist stéréotypes et
impose standard corporel inatteignable
dangereux pour les mannequins adultes le
tout menace en menaçant de même par la
fin de carrière pour certaines et là on
ressort sans surprise que ces
comportements autoritaires et sexistes
génèrent de la détresse psychologique
chez les mannequins ce qui aboutit
souvent à des troubles alimentaires
voire à des comportements à risque tels
que l'automédication l'usage de drogue
pour maigrir ou rester éveillé les
agents sont aussi pointés du doigt pour
ne pas proposer d'accompagnement adéquat
aux mannequins en leur fournissant des
informations nécessaires au bon
déroulement de leur vie professionnelle
ainsi la seule solution qui est
envisagée par l'étude c'est la
Réformation en profondeur des agences un
espèce de d'exercice d'autocritique les
agences doivent commencer à s'éduquer se
sentir concernés par le bien-être des
mannequins tant sur le plan physique que
mental
en partant donc de nos propres sondages
et ainsi que d'études que je viens de
vous présenter nous pouvons constater
que ces jeunes travailleurs dont l'âge
de début de carrière tourne souvent
autour de 16 à 18 ans sont souvent
confrontés à Dieu harcèlement moral la
loi française qualifie de harcèlement
moral des propos ou comportement répétés
qui peuvent entraîner pour la personne
qui les subit une dégradation de ces
conditions de travail ces dégradation
est susceptible de porter atteinte assez
droit et à sa dignité alter et sa santé
physique ou mentale ou encore
compromettre son évolution
professionnelle
52% des mannequins qui ont répondu à
notre sondage le plus récent pense avoir
déjà subi un harcèlement moral dans le
cadre de leur travail de mannequin parmi
les exemples qui reviennent le plus
souvent je pourrais citer quelques-unes
quelques-uns pardon le fait que les
agences laissent souvent comprendre aux
mannequins déjà correspondants aux
attentes de l'industrie par le biais de
commentaires systématique et en direct
qu'il est nécessaire de modifier son
physique
ensuite elle félicite les mannequins
lorsqu'elles se mettent à maigrir
davantage ou maintenir un poids
dangereusement bas nous avons reçu des
témoignages de mannequins qui ont
descendu de 92 cm de tour de hanche à 86
enfin soit elle ferme les yeux sur les
troubles mentaux qui s'installent soit
elle les encourage dans l'étude de
Madame kosciuska il y a eu un témoignage
d'une mannequin qui ne mangeait plus et
ne sortait plus pour être non plus être
confrontés à de la nourriture féliciter
par son agence qui trouvait son
comportement tout à fait professionnel
et exemplaire
une autre technique très répandue c'est
la publication de fausse mensurations
sur les sites web des agences et les
composites les composites ce sont des
espèces de cartes de visite de grande
taille que les mannequins utilisent pour
faire des castings et donc 65% des
mannequins dans notre premier sondage
témoigne de cette pratique cette
pratique pousse en directement les
mannequins à se conformer ou à essayer à
se conformer à des mensurations qui sont
mentionnées sur le site de l'agence de
mon propre expérience par exemple je
pense que je n'ai pas eu surtout les
sites de mes agences à chaque fois
c'était des mensurations différentes
donc chaque agence pensait que je suis
différente voilà on constate donc que le
harcèlement moral peut être à l'origine
des troubles psychologiques et notamment
alimentaires tels que l'anorexie la
boulimie l'horthorexie ou encore la
dysmorphophobie un autre risque pour
professionnel non négligeable mais qui à
mon sens ne rentre pas tout à fait dans
le cadre de la discussion d'aujourd'hui
mais mérite d'être mentionné en ce qui
conduit à des conséquences très graves
pour des personnes qui le subissent ces
dernières années se sont les agressions
sexuelles qui ont attiré l'attention du
public avec des affaires impliquant des
figures importantes du monde de la mode
tel que Jean-Luc Brunel ancien patron de
Karine mode et acteurs clés dans le
réseau de trafic sexuel de Epstein et de
Maxwell qui s'est suicidé en prison et
Gérald Mary ancien directeur d'élite et
ancien président de 8 management qui a
été poursuivi pour viol et agressions
sexuelle mais l'enquête a été close pour
prescription en février 2023 on peut
relever encore une fois le défaut de
mécanisme de protection en place
permettant aux agresseurs potentiels des
personnes très connectées ayant du
pouvoir de l'influence de l'argent de
gravité autour de ces métiers qui sont
liés au corps et de côtoyer des proies
faciles en quelque sorte parce que
mineur parce que jeunes adultes
inexpérimentés souvent étrangères
si on revient vers des dispositifs qui
existent des questions directement
relatives à la santé il convient de
mentionner brièvement quelques
dispositifs donc au niveau législatif
c'est la loi mannequin comme vous l'avez
précisé vous l'avez vous avez présenté
les grandes lignes dans vos proposes en
productifs l'objet principal de cette
loi et de lutter contre l'anorexie chic
un éloignant des podiums et des
magazines les jeunes femmes beaucoup
trop maigres le décret d'application de
2017 à conditionner l'exercice de
l'activité de mannequin à la délivrance
de par la médecine du travail en France
dans certificat médical attestant d'un
état de santé compatible avec l'exercice
du métier de mannequin avec une validité
maximale de deux ans seulement il me
semble que les modalités de suivi des
mannequins étrangères ne résidant pas en
France mais qui exerce leur activité
ponctuellement ont dû être très vite
ajustées en si contenu de la nature très
internationale du métier du mannequin a
été constaté l'impossibilité matérielle
et humaine de faire produire dans les
délais impartis le certificat médical en
France et le suivi médical des
mannequins étrangers ne résidant pas en
France par en médecin de leur pays
d'origine a été privilégiée dans les
cases exceptionnelles d'impossibilité
d'établir un tel certificat dans leur
pays d'origine le recours à un médecin
généraliste français préalablement au
début de la mission
a été leur a été accordé seulement le
nombre très important de mannequins
étrangers présentant sur le sol français
signifie que l'exception que je viens de
vous présenter trouve à s'appliquer plus
souvent que la règle ce qui crée à mon
sens un véritable loopro car il n'existe
pas à ma connaissance de standard
international d'appréciation de
l'aptitude médicale du mannequin à
exercer le métier
un autre lors de la première visite
médicale auprès du CMB en octobre 2017
le médecin a pu me faire part de ses
préoccupations quant à l'efficacité du
dispositif en ce que d'une part certains
mannequins essayer de truquer en quelque
sort le système truqué leur poids en
buvant énormément d'eau avant de passer
la visite pour en fait peser plus à
d'autre part les médecins se sentaient
en quelque sorte responsables s'ils ne
délivrait pas ne serait-ce qu'un
certificat de très courte durée
permettant aux mannequin de ne pas
perdre le contrat mais en leur précisant
de revenir ce quelques semaines et ainsi
de suite
d'autres types de solutions ont été
également proposées par le secteur
notamment privé ce sont des chartes de
bonne conduite la plus connue est celle
signée en 2017 par
lvmhc kerings de travail des mannequins
et leurs bien-être elle fixent notamment
l'âge limite pour participer aux défilé
et shooting des maisons appartenant au
groupe à 16 ans elle précise que les
maisons s'engagent à supprimer de leur
demande de casting la taille 32 chez les
femmes et la taille 42 chez les hommes
ce sont les tailles françaises or ce qui
fait défaut en l'espèce ce sont des
moyens de suivi effectivement de
l'application de laditechart un outre le
fait de bannir une certaine taille de
vêtements ne veut pas dire grand chose
en ce que chaque marque même si elle
appartient en même groupe possède ses
propres références de taille et rendant
encore une fois difficile l'appréciation
de l'efficacité d'une telle mesure ainsi
si 33% des mannequins qui ont répondu à
notre questionnaire n'ont jamais entendu
parler de la dite chart 48% non remarqué
aucun changement notoire depuis sa
rédaction
puisque les dispositifs qui existent
semblent en suffisant pour réduire
l'occurrence et prévenir à terme des
problèmes de santé physique et mentale
parmi les mannequins notre association
souhaiterait encourager le législateur
et les acteurs de l'industrie de la mode
a développé certaines mesures il ressort
de nos statistiques quand l'état actuel
des choses les mannequins se disent
globalement en satisfaits voire très en
satisfait des mesures proposées par les
agences et l'industrie en général
seulement 4 sur 40 ayant répondu être
satisfait il ne semble en si primordial
de recueillir davantage de statistiques
puisque comme je les précisé il n'existe
que très peu d'études dans ce secteur
ainsi une enquête plus globale auprès
notamment du centre de médecine du
travail thali santé permettrait
peut-être de centraliser centraliser les
informations concernant la santé des
mannequins et par disponible
actuellement ensuite cela revient
souvent dans nos sondages il existe un
réel besoin dans une structure agrée
extérieure en dépendant des agences pour
le suivi de mannequin en tant que
représentant mon métier à risque par des
spécialistes formés et cela rejoint
également l'idée de la nécessité
d'introduire des formations et la
certification des agences et des agents
de mannequins qui travaillent avec des
mineurs et des jeunes adultes sans avoir
dans la plupart des cas une
quelconformation leur permettant
d'adopter un mode de communication
adopté et d'évaluer des comportements à
risque si on les réfléchit plutôt à des
mesures de sanctions l'introduction au
niveau législative d'une obligation
d'information pesant sur les agences de
mannequins en tant qu'employeur de
jeunes travailleurs assortis de
sanctions réelles en cas du non-respect
de cette obligation serait très
opportune enfin qu'en est-il de la
possibilité de faire évoluer la sanction
qui pèse sur les mannequins n'ayant pas
obtenu de certificat médical au lieu de
subir une espèce de double peine où le
mannequin par exemple souffre d'un
trouble alimentaire et en plus ne peut
pas exercer le métier nous suggérons le
remplacement de cette interdiction par
le suivi médical approfondi obligatoire
en cas de suspicion de troubles
alimentaires et plus globalement en
suivi médical plus complet et régulier
revient également souvent dans nos
sondages voilà pour conclure j'ai juste
envie de préciser que les problèmes de
santé physique et mentale des mannequins
semblent s'inscrire dans un cadre plus
large d'exploitation psychologique mais
aussi économique de jeunes travailleurs
dans une industrie de la mode qui
monnaie l'esthétique qui menait les
corps je vous remercie pour votre
attention
bien écoutez merci à vous madame pour
cette présentation efficace avec des
propositions et qui forcément amènera
des réactions de la part des rapporteurs
et sénateurs sédatrices qui sont
présents ce matin je passe immédiatement
la parole au docteur Thierry boulanger
qui médecin du travail qui est
accompagné de Yann Hilaire et de
Christine Joly et donc vous allez dans
un premier temps intervenir et vous
répondrez je crois ensuite tous les
trois questions des sénateurs et
sénatrices ces rapporteurs qui sont
présents ce matin merci je vous souhaite
la parole docteur bonjour mesdames merci
madame la Présidente vous l'avez précisé
dans votre propos introductif la loi les
lois de 2016 sont venus préciser les
bases du suivi des mannequins en France
et ce sont bien les deux ministères du
Travail et de la santé qui se sont
appropriés cette question du suivi des
mannequins
le centre médical de la Bourse le CMB
référent dans le spectacle vivant
enregistré depuis une soixantaine
d'années s'est associé avec le CMPC
référent dans la communication et la
publicité pour devenir ta licente en
2021 et ta licente bénéficient d'une
compétence nationale pour le suivi des
intermittents du spectacle des enfants
du spectacle des pigistes et donc des
mannequins et c'est bien l'avenant
numéro 1 de l'accord de branche de 2012
qui a précisé les modalités
organisationnelles et techniques de ce
suivi
depuis 2017 sur le graphique en bas à
droite de la diapositive vous pouvez
voir pour chaque année les effectifs
suivis globalement depuis 2017 nous
avons suivi plusieurs milliers de
mannequins pour être précis plus de 6000
quels sont les données nationales emploi
celle communiqué par audience
précisé déjà en 2015 qu'il existait plus
de 12000 mannequins en France dont
l'essentiel se trouve en région
francilienne et ces mannequins salariés
sont employés par plus d'une centaine
d'agences en bas à gauche de l'écran
vous voyez un histogramme et par tranche
d'âge et vous remarquez immédiatement
que la tranche d'âge 16 30 ans est
particulièrement significativement
féminisé en deçà et au-delà le sexe
ratio n'est pas significatif il y a un
petit peu plus de garçons que de filles
mais c'est surtout sur la tranche d'âge
16 30 ans
la démarche d'identification des risques
repose sur la connaissance du travail
réel en réalité c'est la convention
collective nationale des mannequins qui
précisent tel une pièce de théâtre le
décor et les acteurs et cette convention
collective nationale spécifie les types
de population les mannequins français
les mannequins étrangers résidants en
France les mannequins de 16 à 25 ans de
l'Union européenne ce pays tiers les
mannequins et intermittents les
mannequins occasionnels il existe
également une classification nombre de 6
selon l'expérience selon que le
mannequin est débutant et expérimenté
professionnelle d'un niveau supérieur ou
de renommer internationale enfin il
existe une catégorie de prestations au
nombre de six selon que le mannequin
travaille pour la presse rédactionnelle
les films publicitaires les défilés la
publicité les catalogues les essayages
ou les répétitions
en fait en réalité il y a des
spécificités pour chaque activité dans
l'inconscient collectif on imagine que
le mannequin c'est un mannequin défilé
mais il n'y a pas que les mannequins
défilés il est il est important pour
nous de nous occuper de toutes les
catégories professionnelles de
mannequins
sur la base des éléments des éléments
déclaratifs
issus du colloque singulier médecin
mannequin nous avons pu identifier des
groupes de risques professionnels nous
avons ici positionné sur cette
diapositive les grands groupes que je
vais citer relativement brièvement les
contraintes de travail comme la
multiplicité des lieux de travail les
horaires atypiques le travail de nuit
les postures multiples les déplacements
professionnels les déplacements
internationaux qui peuvent générer un
risque chronobiologique pour le
mannequin le risque routier qui on parle
de déplacements
uber en taxi etc ou en trottinette quand
un mannequin se déplace d'un lieu de son
lieu de son domicile à un lieu de
travail le port de charge
en haut à droite les risques physiques
la lumière artificielle le bruit la
musique amplifiée les ambiances
thermiques et climatiques les nuisances
olfactives les poussières la vie urbaine
les risques biologiques les risques
infectieux du fait de la contamination
inter-humaine et l'épisode de la covid
ne nous a confirmés que effectivement ce
point n'était pas à négliger le risque
parasitaire par l'échange de vêtements
les risques chimiques par les produits
allergisants les produits sensibilisants
et irritants par exemple les parfums les
produits capillaires et cosmétiques les
accidents prépondérants les chutes les
agressions physiques et ou verbales
l'accident routier
et enfin le dernier pavé en bas à gauche
ce sont les risques psychosociaux au
premier rang desquels il y a la
précarité de l'emploi le fait de que le
mannequin puisse travailler avec
plusieurs employeurs et les contraintes
relationnelles et organisationnelles je
vous propose un petit focus précisément
sur les risques psychosociaux
ces contraintes nous les avons
identifiées selon trois grands groupes
organisationsnel relationnels et celle
liées l'emploi concernant les
contraintes organisationnelles citons
les rythmes de travail irréguliers le
travail intermittent l'alternance des
périodes travaillées et des périodes non
travaillées la saisonnalité de
l'activité cela renvoie aux trois grands
événements de la mode de l'hiver de
l'été et de la rentrée chaque année la
gestion de l'équilibre entre travail et
la vie personnelle c'est un élément
important
concernant les contraintes
relationnelles c'est la mise en
concurrence des mannequins on avait
précisé dans le premier slad et
qu'effectivement il y avait une grande
concentration de mannequins en
Île-de-France cela
favorise effectivement la mise en
concurrence de ces salariés la relation
tripartite entre l'agence et
l'entreprise utilisatrice l'agence et
l'employeur du mannequin et le client
c'est l'entreprise utilisatrice
les relations avec les médias mais aussi
les réseaux sociaux ce sont des jeunes
publics qui ont accès à ces réseaux
sociaux comment doivent-ils les gérer
c'est une question à à définir les
contraintes liées à l'emploi la gestion
de l'image la précocité de la première
expérience professionnelle la gestion de
la reconversion professionnelle et enfin
la gestion de la fin de carrière tous
les mannequins sont pas jeunes il y a
aussi des mannequins seniors et il faut
s'occuper d'eux aussi
alors les données de santé
les données bibliographiques sur la
santé des mannequins sont plutôt rares
voir inexistantes mais dès 2019 ta
licence s'est engagée dans un travail
collaboratif dans le cadre d'une thèse
de sciences dont nous attendons encore
les conclusions il ne m'appartient pas
de révéler ses conclusions
parce que nous estimons que nous devons
communiquer sur des éléments fiables et
consolidés au demeurant nous vous
proposons deux de graphes en haut à
droite de l'écran
la courbe vous présente l'évolution de
l'IMC moyen des mannequins femmes de
2017 à 2023 et vous apercevez que sur
l'année 2017
l'IMC moyen était relativement bas
à l'époque nous suivions tous les
mannequins étrangers et français défilés
avant même que la loi n'est plus avoir
des effets bénéfiques sur l'encadrement
et tenir compte de l'imcobal donc en
réalité on avait vu
des mannequins qui résidaient en France
quelques jours quelques semaines et
après il y a eu l'effet de la loi où
effectivement on a resséré ce suivi
encadré et c'est pour cette raison en
partie et d'autres explications que la
courbe imprime une légère progression et
si bien que à partir de 2018 l'IMC moyen
a tendance à augmenter pas de manière
très significative mais elle a tendance
à augmenter encore une fois ces données
doivent être consolidées affinés
alors pourquoi pourquoi cette courbe
augmente-t-elle il y a plusieurs raisons
à cela c'est que il y a l'effet positif
de la loi effectivement de cet
encadrement du suivi des mannequins
d'une part mais aussi par leur
recrutement d'autres catégories de
mannequins nous l'avons vu dans la
présentation de la convention collective
c'est à dire que sont venus intégrer les
effectifs aussi d'autres catégories
comme les mannequins comédiens et
l'effet covid a eu un effet particulier
en ce sens que les comédiens les
comédiens du théâtre
à défaut d'activités théâtrales sont
venus
grossir les rangs parce qu'ils étaient
disponibles pour faire de la publicité
en fait l'IMC moyen d'un comédien et
certainement plus élevé qu'un IMC moyen
d'un mannequin défilé voilà
en bas à droite de l'écran par tranche
d'âge l'IMC moyen des mannequins femmes
que nous avons comparé à toutes les
femmes suivies en 2022
et la petite flèche violette vous
indique sur la tranche d'âge 16-20 ans
que l'IMC moyen est légèrement plus
significatif sur cette tranche d'âge que
sur les autres tranches d'âge donc ça
veut dire qu'il y a un point d'attention
sur les 16 20 ans
pour votre complète information
rappelons quand même que l'OMS définit
ce qu'est une maigreur avec des grades
selon l'IMC l'IMC est une métrique c'est
le poids divisé par taille au carré
cette métrique est nécessaire mais pas
suffisante dans la définition de la
maigrir en bas à gauche de la
diapositive nous avons cité les
prévalences alors pas les prévalences
calculées sur les effectifs de
mannequins suivis par ta lie santé ce
sont des pravalences qui apparaissent
sur toutes les ressources de l'Inserm ou
des fédérations de l'anorexie blueimie
il apparaît que l'anorexie mentale qui
est un trouble psychiatrique rare mais
grave aurait une prévalence de 1,4 %
chez les femmes contre 0,2% chez les
hommes et pour la classe d'âge la
tranche d'âge 15-19 ans cette prévalence
atteint
0,5%. donc vous voyez depuis le début de
mon propos j'insiste beaucoup sur la
tranche d'âge les 16 20 ans
et nous avons cité également la maigreur
constitutionnelle qui n'est pas une
situation pathologique c'est une
situation qui se caractérise par la
résistance à la prise de poids en fait
on peut pas faire la différence entre
une anorexie et une maigreur uniquement
sur les MC cela nécessite un indexatoire
affiné sur tous les déterminants de
santé et qu'est-ce qui fait la
différence entre l'anorexie mentale qui
est une pathologie psychiatrique et la
maigreur constitutionnelle c'est aussi
tous les autres paramètres biologiques
qui sont normaux normaux dans la
maigreur constitutionnelle et la
prévalence de la maigreur
constitutionnelle apparaît selon le MS
en 2020
elle est la prévalence et de 2,7%. donc
en réalité on a plus la probabilité de
voir des mannequins maigres
constitutionnels et plus importante que
la prévalence que la probabilité de voir
des mannequins anorexiques ce sont les
données générales ce sont pas les
données issues de nos propres études qui
sont en cours d'analyse
et remarquer qu'il y avait une enquête
l'enquête aubépi réalisée en 2020 alors
cette enquête était basée sur
l'interrogatoire de plus de 12000
internautes donc ce sont ce n'était pas
des des entretiens en physique mais la
prévalence avait été définie autour de
6,7% pour les femmes contre 2,3% chez
les hommes
alors le suivi en santé des mannequins
diffèrent
selon qu'il s'agit des mannequins
français et étrangers résidant en France
et selon qu'il s'agit de mannequins
étrangers de résidant pas en France
concernant les mannequins français
étrangers résidus en France nous
disposons d'outils d'outils législatifs
qui sont inscrits dans les textes et le
code du travail au premier desquels la
visite d'information et de prévention la
VIP qui est annuelle
qui est réalisée par tout professionnel
de santé les médecins du travail et les
infirmiers en santé au travail alors
pour votre complète information sachez
que ta licence et
de par sa situation géographique dans
l'Île-de-France assure le suivi physique
de ces mannequins en outre les
mannequins d'autres régions sont suivis
par les autres services de santé au
travail de province
le deuxième outil dont on parle souvent
mais il y a donc la vie et le certificat
médical qui lui a une validité de deux
ans maximum ce certificat médical est
délivré par un médecin du travail et
dont les modalités rédactionnelles ont
été visées par l'Ordre des médecins
pour évaluer ce certificat médical
qu'elle est objective c'est pour évaluer
l'état de santé globale au regard de
l'IMC mais comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure l'IMC est nécessaire mais pas
suffisant c'est pour ça que de notre
point de vue et nous avons pas rougir à
avoir noirci une page blanche en 2017
parce que comme nous sommes arrivés
investis du suivi des mannequins il y
avait absolument rien du tout nous avons
tout construit et nous nous félicitons
d'avoir posé les premières briques de
cette de ce grand édifice qui est
totalement perfectible évidemment et
cette audition est sans doute là aussi
pour faire évoluer j'espère madame la
Présidente les choses les données de
santé à collecter reposent un sur le
véhicule au travail c'est essentiel il
convient pour le professionnel de santé
d'aborder les dimensions nutritionnelles
les dimensions somatiques psychologiques
et familiales
on étudie la personne on étudie pas que
le salarié ou la salarié
les données de santé concernent
également la le recueil de paramètres
anthropométriques les cours de
croissance quand on quand on suit des
adultes jeunes des mannequins jeunes il
faut regarder le carnet de santé qu'elle
a été l'évolution staturopondérale de la
personne
et le calcul de l'IMC c'est inscrit dans
les textes
il importe de repérer précocement les
troubles des conduites alimentaires les
TCA
surtout sur la tranche d'âge 15 de 19
ans
si les MC est bas nous nous avons fait
le choix de reconvoquer le mannequin on
ne l'empêche pas de travailler on essaye
de comprendre sa vie
sa vie au travail et sa vie personnelle
autant qu'il est possible de le faire
et si les MC est bas l'attitude du
professionnel de santé doit être à la
fois bienveillante et sans
stigmatisation alors cela cela suppose
que tous les professionnels de santé
soient sensibilisés à cette prise en
charge mais c'est un élément important
les les mannequins viennent nous voir
avec l'idée qu'effectivement ils vont
être évalués selon leur IMC c'est pas la
peine d'ajouter
quelque chose qui risque de les
perturber et qui risque de limiter le
recueil des informations on est là pour
les aider nous sommes là pour les
conseiller les services de santé au
travail sont les conseillers du salarié
de l'employeur et des représentants du
personnel restons bien dans cette
logique nous met ça médecin du travail
nous servir de santé et de prévention en
santé au travail
donc si besoin à revoir le mannequin et
où l'orienter dans la filière soit nous
sommes pas les seuls à suivre le
mannequin nous disposons en France d'un
plateau technique extrêmement performant
utilisons tous ces éléments pour
éventuellement réintégrer la personne
qui poserait éventuellement un problème
de santé dans la filière soit c'est là
le rôle primordial du médecin traitant
et des réseaux d'accompagnement les
fédérations spécialisées dans l'anorexie
la boulimie etc
et si besoin le médecin à peu prescrire
des examens complémentaires de
débrouillage pour essayer de mieux
comprendre encore une fois l'IMC n'est
pas suffisant il faut les payer par
d'autres explorations
et se référer enfin aux recommandations
de bonnes pratiques
las les sociétés savantes mais aussi les
ordres professionnels
s'agissant des mannequins étrangers de
résidant pas en France le législateur a
voulu mettre en place une protection
identique par le médecin du pays
d'origine alors là il est clair que nous
talisant on n'a pas de visibilité et de
lisibilité sur ce suivi là
ce suivi là échappe à notre surveillance
pas notre contrôle on n'est pas dans une
action de contrôle ça échappe à notre
surveillance pour autant il est bien
prescrit dans les textes que le
mannequin étranger ne résidant pas en
France doit se faire remettre un
certificat médical de la même validité
que le nôtre délivré par le médecin du
pays d'origine en français ou en anglais
pour évaluer l'état de santé globale au
regard de l'IMM de l'IMC et avec un
recours possible cela a été dit
précédemment par un médecin généraliste
de ville par un médecin généraliste de
ville pas par un médecin du travail
il existe un autre outil
utile mais peut utiliser finalement et
nous le regrettons c'est la brochure
d'information que nous avons formalisé
très rapidement dès 2018-2019
elle doit être rédigée en français et en
anglais dont l'objectif est d'atteindre
un bon suivi médical des mannequins la
finalité plutôt que l'objectif et cette
brochure d'information précise les
normes de à l'établissement du
certificat médical donc cette brochure
d'information doit être connue
théoriquement de tous les médecins des
pays d'origine mais là on a aucun
contrôle là-dessus
et c'est pour ça que il est important de
rappeler que les médecins des pays
d'origine peuvent prendre la tâche de
notre service pour leur apporter un
maximum d'informations et c'est là aussi
le rôle primordial des agences qui
doivent assurer la diffusion de ces de
cette brochure d'information
mais sur le pan droit de la diapositive
nous Ta licente on n'a pas la visibilité
de tout ça je reviendrai là-dessus pour
ma pesantir davantage sur le sur le
dernier slice si vous me permettez
car enfin le suivi en santé au travail
des mannequins repose aussi sur la
connaissance de leur milieu de travail
les actions en milieu de travail sont
indispensables pas nécessaire elles sont
indispensables pour la réalisation de
notre travail et imaginer un suivi
attentif de ces populations
pour construire une réelle culture de
prévention la prévention c'est la
prévention c'est l'affaire de tous c'est
l'affaire du mannequin c'est l'affaire
des services de santé au travail c'est
l'affaire des agences de mannequins
c'est l'affaire aussi des entreprises
utilisatrices c'est l'affaire aussi de
l'inspection du travail et c'est aussi
l'affaire aussi des associations de
défense
il importe de prioriser les actions de
prévention primaire pour être dans
l'esprit de la loi du 2 août 2021 c'est
important pour mieux accompagner
certains publics notamment les jeunes
mannequins débutants dans ma
présentation mesdames j'avais insisté
sur la tranche d'âge 15 20 ans je pense
à cette tranche d'âge particulièrement
et prévenir la désinsertion
professionnelle qui concerne tous les
âges encore une fois pour rester dans
l'esprit de la loi du 2 août 2021
il convient d'ajuster le suivi
réglementaire contraint en fait mesdames
j'aurais pu marquer trop contraint
au besoin réels des populations selon
les catégories telles que je vous les
avez présentées sur le deuxième la
deuxième diapositive et selon les flux
saisonniers en fonction des événements
de la mode mais n'oublions pas encore
une fois il n'y a pas que les mannequins
défilés il y a aussi les autres
mannequins
obligés à comédien qui se voit remettre
une attestation vide tous les 5 ans et
lui dire pour faire une publicité à la
télévision une fois dans l'année faut
venir tous les ans ça pose problème les
gens n'adhèrent pas ce à cette à ce type
de suivi donc il faut adapter ce suivi
et enfin ajuster le suivi réglementaire
aux capacités des services de prévention
de santé au travail interprofessionnelle
à en assurer la réalisation entre
parenthèses ressources et vie
collectives je vais m'apesantir mais
éventuellement si vous avez des
questions sur ces projets là Yann
Hillaire qui est responsable des projets
pourra répondre précisément à cette
question les ressources quelles sont
elles c'est des Ressources Humaines vous
savez que les professionnels de santé
vivent des grandes difficultés et les
services de santé au travail n'échappent
pas à ce à cette situation il faut tenir
compte de cela comment pouvez-vous
imaginer qu'un service de santé au
travail puisse voir 300 ou 400
mannequins dans un week-end ça suppose
une organisation affinée ajustée
et la vie collective parce qu'en réalité
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que le
système bloque un peu on arrive un petit
peu au pied du mur il faut l'adapter il
faut l'ajuster maintenant nous avons 5 à
6 ans de recul nous savons ce qui est
important de faire il est nous savons
que il y a des populations à suivre de
manière très attentive et nous songeons
aussi nous à d'autres outils de suivi
comme la VIP la visite d'information et
de prévention collective pourquoi
on peut éventuellement imaginer que nos
services de santé au travail puissent se
rendre dans les agences pour voir un
groupe de mannequins et de manière à
pouvoir répondre à l'obligation de
sécurité des agences employeurs en
termes de santé physique et mentale des
mannequins
enfin
évaluer l'état de santé globale du
mannequin en tenant compte de l'IMC et
des autres déterminants de santé y
compris psychosociaux je l'avais précisé
mesdames il importe de ne pas se tenir
au seul IMC il faut aborder tous les
autres déterminants de santé c'était
essentiel et enfin je l'ai rappelé
s'engager également dans des études
médico-psychologiques
socio-démographiques complémentaire et
des échanges de pratiques entre
professionnels de santé à des fins
d'harmonisation du suivi cela a été dit
et je l'ai précisé il importe que entre
professionnels nous puissions échanger
sur un bon suivi un process de suivi il
n'y a pas de norme de suivi de mannequin
à ce jour il n'y a pas de norme nous on
plaide en faveur d'échanges de
d'échanges d'expérience pour que les
sociétés savantes puissent aussi
apporter leur éclairage sur ce suivi des
mannequins
voilà Mesdames merci je tenais
particulièrement à remercier ma collègue
Cécile bar qui est absente mais qui nous
suit vraisemblablement de loin Yann il
est responsable des projets et Christine
Joly qui est directrice du développement
merci mesdames merci Madame le
présidente merci beaucoup pour cette
présentation complète qui vient
compléter très justement la première
intervention de madame qui exerce la
profession donc je vais céder la parole
à notre dernière intervenante de ce
matin Gabriel Schulz et donc qui était
comme je disais tout à l'heure
auteur d'un ouvrage intitulé jeune jolie
et sous-traiter les hôtesses d'accueil
et donc vous êtes madame sociologue du
travail je vous cède la parole avec une
présentation également projetée merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames
messenatrices bonjour merci pour votre
invitation donc je suis effectivement
sociologue du travail à l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin Paris Saclay et
j'ai intitulé cette présentation à
l'intersection de deux rapports de
domination les conditions de travail et
d'emploi des hôtesses d'accueil surtout
veillez bien rester près du micro pour
la facilité du compte-rendu et de
donc je vais baser ma présentation sur
une enquête sociologique de longue durée
que j'ai menée sur les hôtesses
d'accueil prestataires de services entre
2002 et 2011 qui a donné lieu à la
sortie de cet ouvrage en 2018 je vais
pas m'apesantir maintenant sur la
méthodologie mais je pourrais revenir si
vous le souhaitez dans les questions
de quoi s'est-il agile dans cette
enquête à la fois j'ai fait une approche
sociographique des hôtesses donc avec
l'idée de
décrire et quantifier qui elles sont
quelles sont leurs caractéristiques
socio-démographiques elles sont leurs
usages de ce métier comment est-ce
qu'elles y arrivent comment est-ce
qu'elles en sortent et j'ai procédé
également à une analyse de leur activité
et de leurs conditions de travail tout
ça pour vous dire que la question de la
santé au travail n'était pas centrale
dans mon questionnement et que ce que je
vais vous fournir aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt une approche indirecte de la
question de leur santé au travail à
travers la question de leurs conditions
de travail et de la nature de leur
activité qui sont bien évidemment des
déterminants majeurs de leur santé au
travail je vais pas me prononcer sur
leur état de santé je suis pas médecin
alors donc
premier rapport de domination dans
lequel cet emploi est pris et qui
détermine leur activité leur condition
de travail le genre je l'illustre par
cette image donc c'est un cliché qui a
été pris à la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie d'Amiens au salon du
business en mars 2019
cette image à l'avantage de condenser en
un seul clichés les deux imaginaires
féminins sur lesquels reposent
l'activité de test d'accueil la vente et
la maîtresse de maison en effet les
hôtesses d'accueil fournissent un
travail du corps qu'on peut qualifier de
travail décoratif déjà elles sont
recrutées en partie pas seulement mais
elles sont recrutées en partie sur des
critères physiques de poids de taille de
morphologie de jeunesse de beauté de
couleurs de peau également
elles sont affectées aussi sur les
différentes missions en fonction de ces
critères il y a toute une logique
d'affectation qui reprend ses critères
et ce travail décoratif est aussi lié
aux uniformes ou aux costumes qu'on leur
fait porter qui sont généralement
marketées en fonction de l'événement
donc elle fournit ce travail décoratif
mais leur rôle est également défini en
référence à celui de la maîtresse de
maison ce que j'entends par là c'est le
fait que elles effectuent des tâches de
type domestique service de boisson
parfois menu ménage arrosage des plantes
quand elles sont en entreprise mais
surtout au-delà de ces tâches de type de
mystique on attendait au-delà de ça un
état d'esprit qui est celui d'une
maîtresse de maison d'ailleurs on le
leur dit les clients comme les
prestataires qui les emploie leur
demande de se comporter en maîtresse de
maison ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'on
attendent qu'elle se mette à disposition
des besoins de l'organisation qu'elles
soient apte à rendre service et apparaît
à toutes les éventualités là où elles
sont donc on leur demande d'adopter
cette posture alors un autre comment un
autre point commun avec la maîtresse de
maison c'est que du coup ce travail
qu'on leur demande où il s'agit de se
mettre à disposition de rendre service
c'est un travail qui n'est pas reconnu
comme tel qui relativement invisible
comme celui des femmes au foyer qui est
fondée sur le dévouement donc qui ne
connaît pas de limitation c'est pour ça
que j'ai parlé de l'hôtesse femme à tout
faire en effet lors de mon enquête j'ai
été surprise de voir la multiplicité des
rôles quand Dosse les hôtesses d'accueil
qui vont bien au-delà de accueillir et
orienter des visiteurs je vais pas tous
les citer mais on voit très souvent des
hôtesses servir d'assistante avoir des
rôles de commercial de vente avoir des
rôles de traductrice avoir des rôles de
mannequins des rôles de caissières
également de manutentionnaires et tout
cela au tarif d'une hôtesse d'accueil
donc ce qui est intéressant de voir
c'est que
il y a une vraie diversité de leurs
activités et par conséquent aussi des
compétences qui sont requises pour
exercer ce travail mais que il y a une
invisibilisation de cette activité
derrière le terme de test d'accueil et
plus généralement derrière le fait que
l'on vante en permanence leur sourire
aussi bien chez les prestataires que
chez les clients que j'ai interrogé on
m'a toujours dit que la compétence
principale du notes c'était son sourire
donc finalement on invisibilise leur
activité réelle mais aussi les risques
que celle-ci comporte pour revenir à la
problématique de la santé au travail
alors je vous ai mis ici des affiches de
prestataires bien plus qu'un sourire
mais avec une jeune femme qui sourit
qu'on ne voit pas en activité sourire
efficacité écoute encore une fois une
jeune femme qui sourit et ses affiches
de prestataires font plutôt les slogans
des prestataires leur font écho pour
vous donner des slogans qui ont été
usités par des agences Pénélope votre
sourire faites-en un métier le slogan
une petite agence BBO un joli sourire
vaut mieux qu'un long discours
[Musique]
donc il y a un mécanisme
d'invisibilisation de leur activité et
il se double dans notre phénomène qui a
été très bien documenté par la
sociologie du genre qu'on appelle la
naturalisation des compétences
en effet le métier d'hôtesse est ramené
très souvent à une vocation comme
l'illustre cette publicité alors elle
est assez datée mais je la trouve
intéressante c'est une publicité des
années 1970 de l'école Tunon qui
explique donc que finalement les
hôtesses en réalité ne mettent pas en
œuvre des compétences qu'elles
apprennent des savoirs liés à leur
formation mais que finalement elles ne
font que déployer leurs qualités
féminine alors évidemment cette envie
d'utilisation de l'activité cette
naturalisation des compétences ça
aboutit à une dévalorisation
professionnelle des hôtesses d'accueil
elles sont considérées dans les
conventions collectives comme des
employés non qualifiés elles sont payées
au SMIC horaire et pourtant les
statistiques que j'ai pu effectuer
montrent qu'elles sont tout aussi
diplômées que les femmes de leur
génération si on traduit cela veut dire
que dans la mesure où les femmes sont
globalement plus diplômées que les
hommes et que les jeunes générations
sont plus diplômés que les générations
plus âgées en réalité les hôtesses
d'accueil sont bien plus diplômés que la
plupart des personnes avec lesquelles
elles entrent en interaction
donc elle subissent une dévalorisation
professionnelle et cette dévélation
professionnelle contribue à des
interactions qu'on peut qualifier
d'interactions à risque qui les expose
lors des interactions donc avec les
visiteurs elles endoses deux rôles
implicite dans ses interactions que j'ai
nommé la réassurance des identités
hétérosexuées et la relation des
hiérarchies sociales entendre par là la
rassurance des identité des hiérarchies
hétérosexuées qu'il faut qu'elle se plie
à la drague c'est souvent attendu de par
les prestataires et les clients qu'elles
se plient dans une certaine mesure au
jeu je mets des guillemets de la drague
donc ça peut évidemment bien sûr aller
sur du harcèlement réassurance des
hiérarchies sociales car souvent le
nombre est l'inactivité
ostensible des hôtesses sont
proportionnelles à l'importance qui est
accordée aux clients donc plus
l'événement ou les clients vont être
considérés comme important plus il y
aura d'autres tests parfaitement
inactives gênaient d'être dans cette
posture et à disposition finalement donc
en clair le harcèlement sexuel et le
mépris social ne sont jamais bien loin
dans cette activité
je passe au deuxième rapport de
domination dans lequel s'inscrit
l'activité d'accueil après celui du
genre le rapport de sous-traitance en
effet les hôtesses d'accueil ne sont pas
employés par les personnes qui utilisent
directement leur travail qui sont des
clients qui achètent une prestation
elles sont belles et bien en poignées
par des prestataires d'accueil leurs
employeurs officiellement entreprise
prestataire et entreprises clientes sont
des partenaires les sociétés clientes se
recentrent sur leur cœur de métier en
ayant recoin à des prestataires qui sont
spécialisés dans l'accueil pourtant
d'autres logiques bien connues sont
également au cœur des logiques de
sous-traitance un prix moins élevé avec
des conventions collectives moins
favorables dans des sociétés
prestataires où l'expression syndicale
et moindre par rapport à celle des
sociétés clientes des personnels plus
jeunes donc un prix moins élevé mais
également je cite les clients que j'ai
interrogés le confort de ne pas avoir à
gérer de la main d'oeuvre donc pas à ne
pas avoir à gérer une évolution de
carrière ce qui en plus compliqué pour
des hôtesses d'accueil dont un datant
qu'elles ne vieillissent pas le confort
de ne pas avoir à gérer des absences des
congés d'avoir automatiquement quelqu'un
qui va venir remplacer en cas de
problème le confort de ne pas avoir à
recruter de ne pas avoir à licencier et
puis troisième logique une logique de
type disciplinaire quand on est
prestataire personnel externe en quelque
sorte c'est comme si on était toujours
en période d'essai et on est remplacé
immédiatement si quelqu'un juge qu'on ne
fait pas l'affaire donc les rapports
entre sociétés clientes et sociétés
prestataires bien que présenter comme
des rapports de partenariat s'apparente
en réalité beaucoup plus à des rapports
de domination
alors
donc c'est important d'insister
là-dessus parce que ça va avoir un
impact direct en fait sur les conditions
de travail encore une fois des hôtesses
d'accueil c'est à dire que
l'externalisation des hôtesses d'accueil
va faire office quelque part de caisse
de résonance d'une dévalorisation
professionnelle des hôtesses d'accueil
qui est déjà porté en réalité par le
genre par les rapports sociaux de sexe
alors ces conditions dans le travail
d'emploi dégradé je vais pas m'étendre
beaucoup sur là dessus même si c'est au
cœur de ce qui nous intéresse la santé
mais ça ressemble un petit peu à ce qui
a pu être vu pour les mannequins c'est
des horaires imprévisibles des horaires
à rallonge des horaires de nuit du
travail le week-end des lieux de travail
très variés avec des temps de trajet
eux-mêmes très variés la stature debout
toute la journée sur des talons la
difficulté de s'absenter ne serait-ce
que pour aller aux toilettes dans la
mesure où on est censé avoir un rôle de
représentation ou souvent les hôtesses
sont disposés pour former une sorte de
tableau d'ensemble et donc c'est très
compliqué de s'absenter être habillé
trop légèrement et être exposé au
courant d'air en hiver à
et c'est d'autant moins le cas enfin il
y a d'autant moins une prise en charge
que les prestataires décrivent le plus
souvent cet emploi de tests d'accueil
comme un job étudiant je peux vous citer
là-dessus aussi un autre slogan qui a
été hésité par une agence hôtesse un job
malin qui vous va bien donc c'est
considéré comme un job alors certes la
majorité des hôtesses a moins de 25 ans
très clairement mais en accueille en
entreprise mais j'évalue à un cinquième
celle qui ont plus de 30 ans 15% en
accueille événementiel et lors de mon
enquête j'ai croisé plusieurs fois des
femmes qui avaient plus de 55 ans donc
toutes les hôtesses ne sont pas de très
jeunes femmes et puis certes la majorité
des hôtesses est étudiante mais une
partie non négligeable des hôtesses ont
fait son véritable emploi je j'évalue
cette proportion à un tiers des hôtesses
d'accueil on a que en entreprise moins
de 10% par contre en événementiel
beaucoup d'hotesses sont en recherche
d'emploi ou l'utilisent sur le long
terme comme en emploi complémentaire à
une autre activité souvent une activité
artistique
d'écriture ou alors de comédie de chants
etc donc d'écrire cette activité comme
un job étudiant alors que cette
sociographie des hôtesses est bien plus
variée aussi bien en termes d'âge que de
statut ça permet là aussi de se
dédouaner finalement de la
responsabilité sociale envers les
hôtesses d'accueil voilà je vous
remercie pour votre attention
et bien merci beaucoup madame Schutz et
donc je vais laisser la parole aux
questions à nous rapporteurs et aux
sénatrices qui sont encore avec nous
pour cette deuxième table ronde donc je
ne vais pas de main levée qui souhaite
intervenir dans un premier temps
Marie-Pierre annickman et rapporteur
Marie-Pierre Richer merci à vous merci
président écoutez mesdames et messieurs
on vous remercie je pense que ça va être
dit mais vraiment pour la qualité de de
vos propos de de vos présentations il
reste pas beaucoup de questions à vous
poser parce que c'était quand même très
très exhaustif
malgré tout je vais essayer d'en poser
quelques-unes alors je vais commencer
par le mannequinat vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure les réseaux sociaux
j'ai lu un article il y a pas très
longtemps qui parlait de la tendance des
anglo-saxons qui voit l'influence du
phénomène de l'eau en pique je sais pas
si c'est tout à fait ça sur Tik Tok
c'est un Ant un anti-diabétique qui fait
fureur il semblerait dans le métier du
mannequinat avec l'influence de Tik Tok
et je voudrais savoir si ça vous arrivez
à le à le mesurer et comment ces réseaux
entre guillemets peuvent être peuvent
être contournés je pense que c'est pas
très facile et très facile pour ou tout
au moins mettre en garde toutes ces
toutes ces jeunes femmes et je voulais
savoir s'il y avait un suivi aussi quand
elle quitte la profession pour connaître
les conséquences de de leur santé une
fois qu'elles ont quitté le métier parce
que je suppose je suppose je ne suis pas
mannequin ça serait et je n'ai jamais
été mais par la suite si cela a des
conséquences aussi morphologiques sur
leur corps sur leur image toutes les
conséquences psychologiques je suppose
je suppose qu'il y en a et puis je
voulais parler des TMC mais madame vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure avec les
hôtesses d'accueil sur les TMC les
postures les talons etc quels sont les
conséquences physiques
sont aussi les conséquences sur la la
maternité de de ces jeunes femmes parce
que il y a on en a pas parlé mais je
pense que comme ça
il y a une conséquence déjà
morphologique est-ce que ça retarde
aussi ce choix de ce choix de vie
qu'elles en sont les conséquences et
puis madame concernant les hôtesse
d'accueil alors j'étais interpellé parce
que vous avez parlé de l'école Tunon et
on sait que l'école Tino forme également
les hôtesses de l'air en fait tous ces
mots avec qui commence par hôtesse y
a-t-il une étude où avez-vous
connaissance si la différence qu'il peut
y avoir alors je sais que le métier pas
le même mais le sourire
la relation à l'autre etc c'est quand
même des choses que l'on retrouve dans
ces métiers dit d'hôtesse qui a qui sont
quand même assez dévalorisant aussi ce
mot d'hôtesse c'est quand même assez
assez dévalorisant et puis vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure là la couleur de
peau etc donc on tombe quand même dans
quelque chose qui est assez
discriminatoire
est-ce qu'il y a des conséquences par
rapport à ces à cette façon de procéder
merci
merci beaucoup alors peut-être on va
prendre toutes les questions je pense
que c'est plus intéressant vous si vous
pouvez noter les questions et ensuite
vous répartirez les réponses et vous
interviendrez tous comme vous le
souhaitez pour y répondre alors
bien sûr lors d'Archos qui voulait
peut-être avant la rapporteur excusez
devoir poser une question orale dans
l'hémicycle dans pas longtemps c'était
juste pour témoigner que j'avais été
longtemps non pas mannequin justement
hôtesse d'accueil et notamment dans les
salons de prêt-à-porter et il y a toute
une un aspect sexuel qui est en effet
absolument épouvantable enfin on est
aussi entre la dame pipi et et des
poupées vivantes et notamment un salon
de prêt-à-porter sur quatre jours les
personnes qui venaient monter à la
capitale si je puis dire dans les deux
premières journées
draguer d'abord les mannequins qui
étaient dans les rayons et se rabattait
entre guillemets sur les politesse dans
les deux derniers jours de manière
extrêmement lourdingue donc voilà c'est
des souvenirs qui sont pas forcément
très agréables et quand on est très
jeunes parce qu'on peut en fait devenir
avoir des petits jobs d'été et de
week-end assez assez tôt c'est des
souvenirs un peu un peu compliqués je
reprends je vous laisse la parole sur
chers amis chers collègues mais je ça
m'amusait de pouvoir témoigner de de se
passer qui m'est revenu à la figure
merci chers collègues ben on connaît un
peu plus de ta vie d'avant et donc comme
sois rassuré on nous a bien expliqué
tout à l'heure qu'il y avait des
mannequins de tous usage et donc
peut-être que il y aura une autre
carrière qui se dessine devant toi voilà
donc je rappe je repasse la parole à
Madame la rapporteur Annick jacquemais
merci Madame à président live d'abord
merci mesdames et messieurs pour la
qualité de vos exposés très structurées
très documentés
je commencerai par Madame
hoziganova vous nous avez fait part de
l'association que vous avez monté depuis
2017 je voulais savoir déjà si depuis
que vous avez
lancé cette association vous avez vu une
évolution dans votre métier dans la
manière
dont sont prises en charge les
mannequins les jeunes les moins jeunes
et vous nous avez donné un certain
nombre de propositions
que j'ai noté
c'est vraiment là dessus retravailler
est-ce que vous avez déjà commencé à
travailler sur les propositions que vous
avez faites ou est-ce que vous attendez
vraiment que nous on se saisisse de ces
sujets pour vous donner les outils
législatifs qui vous permettront
finalement de de progresser dans le
travail que vous faites et puis
pour les pour les les hôtesses oui vous
nous avez dit qu'au niveau de la santé
c'était pas vraiment le travail que vous
aviez fait mais on a quand même senti
les problématiques qui pouvaient
résulter finalement de ces métiers de
thèse je dirais de tests au sens large
comme à des ma collègue qui peuvent être
finalement des problèmes de stress de
violence de violence sexistes voir
sexuelles et par contre au niveau de la
santé et ce qu'on se rapproche aussi un
peu de la problématique des mannequins
qui doivent pareil surveiller leur corps
surveiller leur ligne surveiller
leur apparence et est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire aussi quels sont les tranches
d'âge est-ce que ça ça
comment dire ça fait appel à des femmes
qui sont très jeunes ou bien on a des
hôtesses après qui perdurent j'allais
dire dans le temps et qui peuvent avoir
des répercussions dans leur vie
d'adultes puisque j'ai bien compris
qu'on commençait à être au test très
jeune et on le voit bien quand on quand
on va dans des salons ou autres et ce
que vous savez justement si ça peut
avoir des répercussions sur leur santé
d'adultes et d'adultes un peu plus
avancé merci trois autres questions donc
prenez bien des notes
Laurence Cohen rapporteur oui à mon tour
de vous remercier parce qu'effectivement
vos propos étaient clairs synthétiques
et ça nous apporte beaucoup pour notre
rapport donc merci
messieurs et mesdames moi je vais être
assez bref parce que mes collègues ont
déjà posé beaucoup de questions mais il
y a une sensibilisation une conscience
collective des violences sexistes et
sexuelles il y a eu tout qui est passé
par là et puis aujourd'hui on voit quand
même que il y a de plus en plus de
femmes qui
osent s'exprimer est-ce que à partir de
là vous avez vu une différence vous dans
à la fois madame comme mannequin et et
Messieurs
sur sur en tant que médecin du travail
sur justement
quelque part les les dénonciations qui
ont pu qui ont pu être faites de
violences sexistes et sexuelles et qui
ont conduit donc à organiser des
accompagnements pour permettre à ces
jeunes femmes de pouvoir aller au bout
éventuellement de plainte ça c'est ma
première question ma deuxième ma
deuxième question c'est elle est un
petit peu on va dire peut-être pas
exactement pas exactement dans le sujet
effectivement de la santé des femmes
mais comme vous vous occupez vous avez
dit Monsieur boulanger que docteur
boulanger que vous vous suiviez
également je crois les enfants mannequin
je voulais savoir si au niveau des
enfants mannequins vous avez senti là
encore on va dire des des
discriminations
sexistes entre les filles et les garçons
c'est à dire que dès le plus jeune âge
est-ce que déjà on demande aux petites
filles d'avoir une certaine taille un
certain poids etc une certaine apparence
voilà est-ce que ça commence très tôt
si mesdames les rapporteurs et donc pour
terminer ce tour de table victoire
jasmin et elles achète
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente et
merci mesdames et messieurs pour vous
interventions alors j'ai une question
concernant les comportements Harry c'est
surtout pour le docteur boulanger et
comportement à risque quelquefois
observés à part effectivement la
nourrexie et tout le reste mais par
rapport aux drogues aux produits
addictifs
alors est-ce que vous vous rendez compte
de cela également et vous
accompagner les personnes vers d'autres
professionnels quand c'est le cas et
l'autre chose concernant
l'accompagnement également en fonction
de l'âge par exemple pour les mannequins
pour les professionnels en tout cas
vieillissant
est-ce que vous vous accompagnez parce
que bon c'est quelquefois difficile pour
ces personnes de changer de métier
d'avoir d'autres activités mais est-ce
que vous contribuez également au Conseil
et à leur réorientation professionnelle
je dirais merci beaucoup
et donc notre collègue elle s'achal qui
est rapporteur mais sur un autre dossier
sur lequel on travaille qui rapporteur
sur la parentalité dans des territoires
ultramarins ça fait le lien avec
Victoire jasmin qui est en provenance de
Guadeloupe voilà merci madame la
Présidente à mon tour de vous remercier
pour vos interventions et pour la clarté
des présentations que vous nous avez
faites j'avais une question peut-être
qui s'adressait au docteur boulanger par
rapport en fait à la prévention où vous
nous avez dit effectivement à quel point
la prévention était essentielle et la
prévention et l'affaire de tous vous
avez effectivement
accentué je crois juste titre sur cette
tranche d'âge qui doit mobiliser et
appeler peut-être aussi une attention
toute particulière concernant des
publics peut-être plus sensibles plus
jeunes et pour lequel nous savons à quel
point au moment notamment de
l'adolescence justement la
représentation du corps de l'image et
notamment avec ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure avec des réseaux sociaux peut
avoir un impact tout particulier et
singulièrement dans la période que nous
vivons d'où ma question est-ce qu'il y a
un travail qui est mené ou qui devrait
être mené d'après vous peut-être avec le
rectorat mais également avec les parents
parce qu'on sait à quel point la
question de l'orientation
professionnelle et et important et
singulier et souvent en fait justement
les jeunes femmes ont tout un attrait
pour pour peut-être le mannequinat mais
également en fait justement des métiers
en fait de représentation et ce que
justement dans ce cadre là en lien aussi
avec le travail que nous menons au sein
de la commission culture et éducation
est-ce que d'après vous il y a justement
des actions à opérer ou peut-être des
collaborations plus étroites à faire je
vous remercie
et bien écoutez maintenant place aux
réponses et donc je crois que le docteur
boulanger était prêt à répondre et puis
après vous prenez la parole les uns les
autres comme vous l'entendez merci oui
merci Madame j'ai tenté de reprendre de
noter toutes vos questions elles sont
nombreuses je vous en remercie je vais
commencer par la question de madame
Richard concernant le suivi post
professionnel alors c'est c'est un
système de suivi qui est inscrit dans la
loi du 2 août 2021 et dans ses décrets
de mémoire à ma connaissance l'activité
de mannequin expose pas des risques
particuliers et donc cela ne renverrait
pas a priori sur un suivi post
professionnel
ça c'est le premier élément concernant
le suivi de grossesse votre question est
éminemment intéressante parce que
effectivement après l'accouchement le
mannequin qui est mannequin salarié
il est sous la responsabilité de
l'employeur et l'employeur est crédité
d'une obligation de sécurité en matière
de santé physique et mentale et qu'à ce
titre au retour de de de de de congé
maternité
la la femme mannequin doit retrouver son
poste la femme mannequin doit aussi
bénéficier d'un entretien professionnel
et la femme mannequin 10 semaines après
son retour de l'accouchement
bénéficie d'un statut protégé pendant 10
semaines ça c'est le suivi après la
après l'accouchement donc il y a des
dispositifs qui sont utilisés encore
faut-il que l'employeur l'agence
employeur soit bien informé et c'est
nous c'est le rôle que nous avons aussi
de conseiller l'employeur on s'intéresse
pas qu'aux mannequin en fait je vous ai
je voulais rappeler tout à l'heure
madame c'est que nous sommes le
conseiller du salarié de l'employeur et
des représentants du personnel enfin il
y a certains éléments de contact
concernant enfin en tout cas en termes
d'échange avec les agences ça cet
élément éminemment perfectible on a on a
on a peu de d'accroche ou d'attache avec
les agences et nous le regrettons nous
nous appelons de nos vœux justement
cette communication plus affinée plus
plus régulière avec les agences de
mannequins dans quel objectif pour que
les salariés puissent les salariés
mannequins puissent exercer dans de
bonnes conditions leur emploi
concernant la prévention des faits de
harcèlement je rappelle à toute fin
utile que les services de prévention et
de santé au travail sont inscrits dans
une logique de prévention pas de
prohibition tout ce qu'il s'agit
tous les faits de supposés de
harcèlement de comportement sexistes
il y a une action
interne à l'entreprise qui doit être
mise en place il y a après la justice
peut être saisie de tel fait nous on est
là pour prévenir le risque
on fait en sorte que les choses
n'arrivent pas à condition qu'il y ait
une information
extrêmement bien réfléchie
entre tous les acteurs internes de
l'entreprise c'est-à-dire de l'agence
avec ses salariés mais aussi en dehors
de en dehors de l'enceinte de
l'entreprise
concernant les porte les comportements à
risque effectivement madame nous nous
insistons sur ces éléments-là alors
comme les mannequins sont
essentiellement concentrés si je puis
dire en région francilienne c'est une
région urbaine avec toutes ces joies et
ses difficultés que vous connaissez donc
nous insistons là dessus au
effectivement sur les les comportements
ou les conduites addictives donc on
interroge les on interroge les
mannequins et généralement globalement
les mannequins se livrent assez assez
ouvertement on a ce lien de confiance je
parlais de coloc singulier entre le
salarié et le médecin ça ça nous est
utile je pense que globalement les
mannequins nous sentent comme des des
gens partenaires pour les aider les
conseiller et on veut effectivement
maintenir cette cette état d'esprit et
pas nous positionner comme des comme des
gendarmes ou comme comme le juge ça
c'est important c'est la relation de
confiance avant nous appeler service de
médecine du travail enfin nous sommes
professionnels de santé nous sommes des
médecins et des infirmiers nous avons ce
gène là pour ainsi situer une relation
de confiance et si la relation de
confiance est là nous pourrons
recueillir un maximum d'informations et
sensibiliser faire la prévention sur les
addictions c'est important surtout à
Paris et dans les dans les grandes
villes mais j'observe ici au-delà quand
même que même dans les petites villes il
y a des problèmes d'addiction
particuliers quand même donc tout le
territoire national est concerné
s'agissant de la prévention essentielle
effectivement madame vous avez raison je
le disais tout à l'heure la prévention
c'est une affaire de tous et nous on
envisage aussi non pas d'aller plus
souvent encore plus souvent dans les
agences mais aussi on imagine aussi
d'autres interventions dans le milieu
scolaire dans le milieu universitaire ce
sont des populations jeunes qu'il faut
sensibiliser il faut croiser nos
énergies il faut croiser nos expériences
et intensifier la communication pour que
la prévention primaire puisse prendre
tout son sens c'est ça l'essentiel et la
prévention primaire c'est quoi c'est
tout mettre en place avant que le
dommage survienne
et c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup
l'esprit de la loi du 2 août 2021 parce
que elle met l'accent sur cette
prévention primaire à condition que tous
les acteurs puissent échanger entre eux
alors madame shody qui souhaitait
intervenir tout à fait au nom de ta
santé et des actions que nous
développons d'abord je vous remercie
pour toutes les questions qui ont été
posées parce que je trouve qu'elle
rentre bien dans le cadre de ce qui est
débattu ce matin et sur les actions que
l'on peut en tout cas vous sur lesquels
on peut vous solliciter puisque c'est
aussi le but de ceci
on travaille beaucoup avec les
fédérations en tant que service de santé
au travail de prévention la loi du 2
août elle l'a bien spécifié et justement
je trouve que c'est intéressant parce
que vraiment on voudrait accentuer notre
présence sur les lieux aussi les défilés
les podiums c'est difficile de pénétrer
ces lieux là alors on a on a une avancée
une première avancée puisque Chanel LVMH
on dit qu'ils étaient d'accord mais
enfin il faut arriver se faire oublier
enfin or je crois beaucoup à la
pédagogie qu'on peut développer avec
entre les services de santé au travail
évidemment et les agences mais aussi
avec les consommateurs finaux qui sont
aussi ces grandes marques de donc je
pense que on aurait intérêt
effectivement dans une démarche la plus
plus globale on parle on sort du
colloque singulier pour dire voilà il
faut aussi qu'on puisse constater il
faut que le médecin puisse aller sur
place mais aussi je rappelle qu'on a une
équipe pluridisciplinaire qui peut
intervenir aussi à la demande ou sur le
repérage de certains risques et c'est
intéressant aussi d'une manière plus
collective de voir si une société
au-delà des effets d'annonces au-delà de
du fait de demander des certificats tous
les six mois au lieu de tous les ans
puissent aussi être un peu interpellé
sur la manière dont elle conduit aussi
les actions en milieu de travail de tous
ces de toutes ces de tous ces mannequins
qui nous tiennent à cœur ta licente
vraiment même si le modèle économique
est pas très bon parce que entre les
mannequins qui se doivent être vus et
qui se participe à une publicité et puis
ceux qui sont vus parce qu'effectivement
ils sont sur les podiums et ils ont une
urgence et c'est une régularité dans ce
dans ce colloque organisé bien écoutez
on a on a du mal à fixer la norme le
nombre l'effectif que l'on doit suivre
et c'est un vrai problème parce que du
coup c'est vous imaginez bien que nos
médecins sont très sollicités voilà
après sur la prévention justement juste
un point et après je passerai la parole
ce qui nous paraît très important
maintenant c'est aussi on travaille
beaucoup avec avec l'équipe il faut
savoir que les médecins sont très formés
que le docteur boulanger où il y a ni
l'air participe beaucoup à des modules
de formation aussi pour que tous les
médecins soient vraiment très formés aux
coloc et au repérage des risques mais je
pense qu'il faut aussi et donc on est
sur cette démarche là de constitution
aussi de modules de prévention qui
soient accessibles et où on puisse
vraiment faire cette oeuvre de
prévention qui est qui est attendue et
qui est absolument indispensable aussi
que n'importe quel mannequin puisse
aussi accéder à un module et être formé
aussi
sur
l'alimentation sur le sommeil sur tous
les troubles qui peuvent survenir au
cours de sa vie professionnelle qu'on
espère longue et fructueuse pour elle
aussi voilà merci alors
oui mais on va juste compléter les
questions par celle de Martine en même
temps oui oui c'est pour ça donc ah
pardon
oui madame Cohen oui concernant le suivi
des enfants mineurs de moins de 16 ans
c'est à la charge d'un pôle du Pôle
emploi dont je m'occupe pas mais en
réalité le suivi des enfants du
spectacle y compris des mannequins de
moins de 16 ans sont rattachés sous la
responsabilité du pôle du pôle enfant
mais en toute chose c'est que ce suivi
de ses enfants ou de ces jeunes
adolescents répond à une réglementation
extrêmement extrêmement stricte avec des
commissions un suivi
médico-psychologique et pédagogique donc
si déjà le suivi des mannequins de plus
de 16 ans et adultes et et stricte
encadré et on peut se féliciter de
l'esprit de la loi des lois de 2016 en
tous les cas le suivi des enfants est
encore beaucoup plus encore plus stricte
et on évoque effectivement
les aspects à la fois de représentation
de l'image
l'alimentation sur tous les aspects
nutritionnels familiaux la croissance
etc c'est extrêmement extrêmement précis
et il n'y a que de rares médecins dans
notre service qui s'occupe de Paul parce
que cela demande une expertise
particulière on suit l'enfant mais aussi
les parents c'est un double suivi
parallèle
on complète les questions avant que vous
continuez à répondre avec une question
de Martine filleul oui merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais vous remercier
également tous de vos propos très
structurés et très documentés
monsieur boulanger vous avez évoqué mais
je trouve trop brièvement la situation
des mannequins étrangers est-ce que vous
pourriez revenir quelques instants sur
leur situation est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'elle est plus précaire
encore que les autres et que le suivi de
ces mannequins étrangers au moins d'un
point de vue médical est encore moindre
que les autres
comme je vous le préciser madame tout à
l'heure nous n'avons pas de visibilité
précise sur le suivi des mannequins
étrangers nos résidant pas en France il
y a pas de communication alors certains
pays peuvent étudier certaines de leurs
populations nous nous avons la chance en
France de disposer d'un suivi centralisé
par la désignation de Thalie santé
excelb donc ça facilite un peu la
collecte des informations mais à ce jour
madame nous ne disposons d'aucune donnée
scientifique communicable consolider
concernant l'état de santé des
mannequins étrangers résidant nos
résidant pas en France peut-être que
Madame
hoziganova souhaite compléter
puisqu'elle a évoqué ce sujet tout à
l'heure avec des focus sur la loi oui en
effet si on regarde la situation des
mannequins étrangers donc le suivi est
assuré normalement soit dans leur pays
d'origine soit si cela n'a pas été
effectué donc sur le territoire français
et
modelo est beaucoup sollicité par les
mannequins étrangers j'avoue que notre
sujet notre cheval de bataille on va
dire c'est plutôt tout ce qui est aspect
législatif tout ce qui est l'économie
les dettes etc auprès des agences donc
on se concentre moins sur la santé même
si ce pas en nous intéresse beaucoup
donc on peut pas dire qu'on reçoit
beaucoup de messages ou de plaintes de
la part des mannequins étrangers
concernant le suivi médical
en revanche comme je l'ai précisé dans
ma présentation je pense que le fait
qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de standard on
va dire international en matière de
comment on évalue
l'état de santé de mannequins qui serait
considéré comme apte à exercer le métier
je pense que c'est problématique parce
que le domaine le métier en lui-même est
hyper international surtout si on prend
les mannequins de défiler et c'est
surtout souvent les mannequins de
défilés qui sont les plus maigres qui
sont le plus touchés par l'anorexie ou
par la boulimie en tout cas de ce qu'on
constate
merci madame la Présidente juste pour
compléter ma réponse madame à défaut de
visibilité sur l'état de santé des
mannequins étrangers dans le reste du
monde c'est un appel du coeur que nous
lançons à savoir que la France doit
pouvoir échanger aussi avec les autres
pays étrangers pour justement construire
les bases et un questionnement sur
l'état de santé des mannequins parce
qu'en réalité la France et
le métier de la mode alors je disais
tout à l'heure que les mannequin n'est
pas qu'un maintien un mannequin défilé
mais pour autant la France de part sa
situation vis-à-vis de la mode par
exemple est un lieu de concentration et
de et de rencontres des mannequins donc
nous jouissons d'une situation
géographique éminemment importante et
Paris en l'espèce l'est aussi donc nous
nous appelons aussi nos confrères
étrangers à pouvoir partager leurs
connaissances
merci beaucoup est-ce que je pense que
Monsieur peut être Hilaire souhaitait
compléter les merci parce qu'une
question notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux on n'a pas répondu et peut-être
préciser la question des enfants du
spectacle et de la prévention primaire
concernant les réseaux sociaux alors le
les métiers du mannequinat ils sont
soumis comme d'autres à la population
notamment conçu également notamment les
jeunes artistes et cette pression est
assez nouvelle c'est un nouveau facteur
de risque psychosociaux majeur pour pour
ces populations là qui répond aussi à un
biocognitif important bien cognitif
humain qui est bien connu en neuroscien
c'est en psycho en psychologie c'est que
tout ce qui se passe sur ces réseaux là
à partir du moment où il y a un groupe
qui pointe du doigt quelque chose un
élément qui comme vous citiez le
médicament tout à l'heure il va être
utilisé plus naturellement c'est un
biais cognitif c'est très connu depuis
les années 50
et les réseaux sociaux
facilitent en fait ce biais là nous nous
sommes en grande réflexion sur
l'utilisation des réseaux sociaux parce
que nous avons des populations
plutôt jeunes qui ont du mal et qui sont
totalement exposés à la vindicte
populaire sur ces réseaux
[Musique]
je suis peut-être pas qualifié pour
commenter l'addiction aux réseaux
sociaux ou autre chose mais vous non
mais vous avez raison la question se
pose dans ce terme-là je suis assez
d'accord la question des enfants donc
nous on suit beaucoup plus des enfants
du spectacle pour les enfants mineurs et
la commission d'en parler le docteur
boulanger et
plus riz institutionnel on a la justice
qui siège dans ces commissions on a le
rectorat vous en discutiez on en parlait
tout à l'heure il y a nos médecins de ta
santé et chacun met les enjeux
au centre des discussions pour pouvoir
autoriser ou non des populations
particulières de travailler et je n'ai
pas de statistiques sur les questions de
discrimination sur les populations de
jeunes enfants mannequins on s'en est
rarement enfin on a rarement interrogé
cette question là enfin pour finir et je
trouve que les deux sujets sont
extrêmement pertinents l'un avec l'autre
c'est la question de la de la
sous-traitance et la question de
l'intermédiation entre un salarié et un
employeur toute la construction de la
loi autour de la prévention de la santé
au travail et construit sur un triptyque
un salarié un contrat de travail un
employeur les deux populations qu'on a
discuté aujourd'hui à un intermédiaire
entre le salarié et l'employeur nous
rencontrons de grandes difficultés à
accéder au travail tout à l'heure quand
le docteur boulanger vous parlez de
prévention et d'accès au travail réel
nous n'avons aujourd'hui et depuis 2017
jamais pu en tout cas les médecins du
travail assistaient à un défilé jamais
nous n'approuve plus jamais rentrer dans
une séance de shooting le seul défilé
qu'on a pu observer avec une collègue
ingénieur HSE c'était qu'on y était pour
les questions des caméraman qui
filmaient le le travail des des
mannequins ainsi de suite je pense que
la question si on veut améliorer que ce
soit la question de la santé au travail
des hôtesses ou des mannequins il faut
donner accès plus facilement aux
institutions en charge de la prévention
de la santé au travail
et de faire une vraie mise en débat de
ces conditions entre les entreprises
utilisatrices les entreprises qui
embauchent ces populations et les
salariés eux-mêmes
merci madame osicanova qui souhaitait
compléter également je voulais juste
compléter sur la question relative aux
réseaux sociaux notamment parce que il
me semble que la promotion quand même de
mauvaise pratique est assez présente
dans ce milieu et cela va même de la
part des agents donc il est difficile
certes de contrôler la propagation de ce
genre d'information même si un espace
vous parlez d'anti diabétique qui est
donc fait fureur sur TikTok et c'est pas
les agences qui le mettent évidemment
sur TikTok mais voilà c'est ça ça vient
c'est une influence il y aura un autre
médicament peut-être demain et il arrive
en effet que les agences peuvent
orienter elles-mêmes les mannequins vers
des pratiques qui sont souvent douteuses
et non scientifiques en matière de
nutrition tiens il y a un nouvelle
manière de manger vas-y test peut-être
tu seras mieux demain donc voilà je
pense que dans ce milieu un effet
l'influence des réseaux l'influence
aussi des agences sur les mannequins
souvent très jeunes comme je les
précisais et les très très présente
et sinon ce que je peux répondre à des
questions relatives ok donc Madame
Jacquemet et qui n'est plus là m'a posé
une question sur l'évolution dans le
métier depuis la création de
l'association en effet je pense qu'on
peut constater que si en 2017
une omerta quasi totale autour des
questions qui touchaient à peu près à
tous les aspects du métier était très
présente en France comme ailleurs il y
avait quelques initiatives qui étaient
déjà en place notamment aux États-Unis
mais disons que France qui était quand
même capital capital de la mode en
quelque sorte le rencontre le plus
important de l'année autour de la
Fashion Week etc il y avait pas
d'initiatives il y avait pas d'union
syndicale il y avait il y avait vraiment
rien pour les mannequins il y avait des
unions syndicales pour les agences de
mannequins qui disaient on va
représenter aussi des mannequins or
c'est de point de vue même dit l'idée
c'est c'est impossible comment un
employeur peut représenter un employé et
donc
je pense que on peut on peut dire que
depuis la création et depuis qu'on fasse
énormément de travail auprès des médias
auprès du public il y a les questions de
respect les conditions du travail
notamment à des conditions financières
des conditions de d'exercices du métier
en lui-même des questions de santé aussi
ont été mis sur le devant de la scène et
je pense que
beaucoup de mannequins SANS saisissent
et on parle on reçoit énormément de
questions on reçoit énormément de retour
et depuis 2017 il y a également d'autres
initiatives qui ont été lancées
notamment au Pays-Bas en Angleterre donc
il y a des groupes de mannequins qui
s'organisent et qui essayent de
contribuer à au changement et en ce qui
concerne donc nos propositions et si
nous avons déjà commencé le travail ou
pas
évidemment certains aspects je pense ne
sont pas accessibles à un public comme
association oui il y a des propositions
comme par exemple obligations
d'informations ça c'est clairement c'est
le législateur qui ne peut se saisir de
cette question qui ne peut que se saisir
de cette question
en revanche en ce qui concerne par
exemple la promotion des bonnes
informations et en bonne pratique oui en
effet nous avons rédigé un guide
juridique à destination des mannequins
un partenariat avec les élèves avocats
de l'école de formation du barreau on
est en train de peaufiner les derniers
détails mais on compte le publier très
prochainement donc ça je pense que c'est
déjà assez important car il n'existe pas
vraiment de repères les agences ne
fournissent pas les informations aux
jeunes mannequins et souvent elles
arrivent elles ne savent même pas qu'ils
sont dans un rapport salarié avec leur
agence donc voilà et sinon madame Cohen
m'avait posé également une question sur
la capacité de s'exprimer davantage sur
les violences sexistes et sexuelles il
me semble que les questions de corps en
général ont beaucoup moins de mal à
comment dire à j'ai l'impression que les
questions de corps sont souvent plus
facilement traités avec plus de volonté
et aussi avec un regard plus
bienveillant de la part des agences
notamment tandis que quand on touche à
des conditions de travail là ça devient
ça commence à coincer un petit peu parce
que c'est des questions qui touchent à
l'argent des questions qui touchent à
des conditions de travail donc ça ça
devient problématique donc je pense que
heureusement tout ce qui touche au tabou
autour des relations autour des
violences sexistes et sexuelles ce tabou
commence petit à petit à reculer et
nous on croit néanmoins que l'origine
des violences sexuelles et sexy se
trouve souvent dans l'exploitation
économique néanmoins des travailleurs
dont le statut en France est très
particulier c'est ce lien de dépendance
qui caractérise un contrat de travail
qui existe en France entre le mannequin
l'agence et le client et il y a une
prohibition même Express d'exercer le
métier en tant que indépendance si on
n'est pas un mannequin qui est installé
régulièrement dans l'Union européenne et
qui dispose d'un statut similaire qui
lui permet ponctuellement d'exercer le
métier à caractère en tant
qu'indépendant en France voilà moi il me
semble que quand même ces questions
méritent d'être étudiées
et bien écoutez je pense vous souhaitiez
répondre aussi madame je sais pas vous
m'aviez pas signalé donc je n'ai pas
pardon oui
je veux bien je sais qu'il est tard mais
je veux bien me répondre aux questions
qui m'ont été posées et rebondir très
rapidement sur ce qu'elle dit Monsieur
Hilaire sur la question de la
sous-traitance elle empêche bien
évidemment l'accès de la santé au
travail mais elle empêche aussi l'accès
des inspecteurs du travail ça aussi
c'est très important de le signaler il y
a des délits d'obstruction permanents
moi j'ai dans mon enquête j'en ai
rencontré plusieurs qui m'ont évoqué la
difficulté de contrôler les conditions
de travail des personnels sous-traités
donc je pense c'est vraiment un des
nœuds de ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui
donc Madame Richer m'avait demandé la
similarité enfin les points communs avec
des hôtesses de l'air donc je peux que
vous approuver il faut savoir que les
agences d'hôtesse d'accueil pour la
plupart ont été créés à l'origine par
des anciennes hôtesses de l'air des
agences d'accueil potentiel donc qui
était elle-même hôtesse de l'air les
chartes qu'elles mettent en place on en
a pas parlé mais en fait les hôtesses
d'accueil doivent signer des chartes qui
décrivent de manière extrêmement précise
leur tenue le type de bijou qu'elles
peuvent porter le type de maquillage
qu'elle doit mettre le grammage des
collant cher qu'elles doivent porter
enfin c'est extrêmement rigoureux ces
chartes sont directement inspirés de
celle de l'aviation commerciale qui
avait cours cher France dont beaucoup de
fondatrices de sociétés prestataires
d'accueil éventuelles sont issus donc ça
c'est en premier lien le deuxième lien
je disais qu'il y avait pas que des
étudiantes qui avaient un certain nombre
de personnes qui exercent cette activité
en complément d'une autre activité j'ai
dit le plus souvent artistique c'est
aussi beaucoup des hôtesses de l'air
puisque les hôtesses de l'air pour la
plupart c'est quand même assez rare
d'être cher France en CDI on est
beaucoup plus souvent dans des agences
low cost avec des CDD saisonniers et en
fait on a beaucoup qui alternent en fait
hôtesse d'accueil et hôtesse de l'air
donc les liens sont effectivement
multiples tant sur l'inspiration que
dans la porosité en fait des personnes
qui exercent qui exercent les deux
métiers vous avez relevé en effet que
l'âge la couleur de peau le poids on
était sur des questions à
discriminatoires et vous êtes étonné
qu'il n'y ait pas forcément de
conséquences ou m'avait demandé si on
avait
moi je vous répondrai que pour agir
contre les discriminations il faut une
mobilisation soit individuelle soit
collective et que dans les deux cas en
fait peu de critères sont réunis pour
que ces mobilisations aient lieu en ce
qui concerne des mobilisations
individuelles à les saisir l'inspection
du travail au-delà de la difficulté
encore une fois de saisir l'inspection
du travail dans ce contexte
d'externalisation
il faut avoir un rapport au métier qui
veut dire que c'est quelque chose
d'important pour les jeunes femmes qui
l'utilisent comme un job étudiant elle
n'investissent pas leur identité dans ce
métier ce métier doit avant tout leur
servir donc généralement elle ne
s'épuise pas en défendre les contours
alors évidemment on peut voir des
exceptions on a eu le hashtag qui a été
évoqué patapotish mais donc le rapport
au travail notamment pour les personnes
dont ce n'est pas l'activité principal
ne les incitent pas à se battre en fait
pour réagir aux discriminations quant
aux mobilisation collective je
reviendrai encore sur la question de
l'externalisation le fait que les
hôtesse d'accueil sont très isolés alors
il y a évidemment des événements qui ont
réunissent beaucoup d'un seul coup on
pense au Salon de l'automobile on
parlait du salon la lingerie mais très
souvent c'est des événements où elles
vont être deux trois quatre tests
d'accueil c'est jamais les mêmes groupes
qui se reconstituent donc c'est
difficile de construire quelque chose de
collectif et en plus ces groupes peuvent
réunir des hôtesses d'accueil qui ont
elles-mêmes en rapport à ce travail très
différents entre celles qui se vivent
comme des professionnels qui sont tout à
fait minoritaires et celles qui vivent
comme un travail à côté donc il y a
quand même globalement très peu de
mobilisation donc du coup les
discriminations finalement
perdure sans qui est grand chose qui
soit fait donc Annick jacquemais avait
posé la question de la surveillance du
poids et de l'apparence bien évidemment
c'est également vrai dans les métiers
d'accueil
comme dans ceux du mannequinat mais dans
des proportions bien moindres pour
illustrer on parlait tout en détail 32
bon bah les agences de test procurent
des uniformes en taille 36 38 40 mais
pas 42 mais certainement pas 34 32 donc
on n'est pas sur des problématiques de
l'anorexie en revanche il y a évidemment
des pratiques de la part des hôtesses
d'entretien de leur corps ce qui prend
du temps ce qui est également coûteux en
terme de soins apportés à ce corps qui
se sont pas pris en charge et donc
est-ce que les hôtesses perdurent
c'était la dernière question donc oui il
y a 20% des hôtesses qui ont plus de 30
ans généralement elles vont pas être
affectées exactement au même mission je
disais que l'affectation dépendait de
critères physiques et en termes de
couleurs de peau de poids etc mais
également en termes d'âge on va être
plutôt sur du back office si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi ou sur des fonctions ou
justement va être un petit peu moins
debout donc un petit peu moins exposé en
tout cas à des pénibilités de type
statique pas forcément moins exposées
aux violences sexistes et sexuelles en
revanche
voilà je vous remercie et bien écoutez
merci Madame shout ça aurait été dommage
de se priver de vos réponses voilà mais
je ne vous avais pas vu faire des signes
donc je voudrais pas vous obliger à
répondre non plus et comme vous le voyez
il y a d'autres réunions qui
s'enchaînent mais vraiment je tenais à
vous remercier parce que cette table
ronde a été à la fois très intéressante
sur le diagnostic et aussi très
intéressante au niveau des propositions
que vous avez pu faire chacun et chacune
d'entre vous sur sur les améliorations
possibles ou les pistes peut-être
législatives à trouver donc merci à vous
mesdames et messieurs pour la qualité de
du travail que vous avez dû mener en
amont de cette réunion du rendu et
toutes les réponses qui ont été
apportées au collège rapporteur et au
collègues sénateur et sénatrice qui
était là ce matin avec nous en réunion
merci bonne journée merci